sans surprise on en a marre j'espère que
non parce que j'en ai marre comme vous
mais au vu de l'évolution positive que
prennent les courbes du coc vienne le
gouvernement a annoncé que de masquer en
extérieur n'était plus obligatoire
nous allons lever l'obligation générale
du port du masque un extérieur nous
sommes d'aller à votre rencontre pour
savoir si vous alliez continuer à le
porter même si vous n'y est plus obligé
alors les français vont ses gardes et le
masque on y répondant facture même si la
majorité des français en ont
définitivement marc démarre en extérieur
je compte pas le mettre effectivement
parce que ça fait quand même un bout de
temps que ça commence à vraiment bon bp
qua non je ne continuerai pas à mettre
le masque
certains d'entre nous préférez le gain
je continuerai à porter le masque mais
que dans les endroits fermés
ce que j'ai remarqué que ces derniers
temps je l'attrapé beaucoup moins
d'angine beaucoup moins de malades
gisent d'après la question du jour du
figaro datant du 14 juin sur dix sept
mille votants
75 % des personnes sondées étaient déjà
favorables à l'abandon du port du masque
en extérieur et ça tombe bien puisque le
16 juin 2021
jean castex annoncé la levée de
l'obligation du port du masque en
extérieur avec presque deux semaines
avance sur le calendrier initial fixé
par emmanuel macron fin avril cette
initiative du gouvernement s'explique
tout simplement par les chiffres du cor
vide qui tentent de tous à la baisse
mais on peut quand même se demander s'il
y a un réel risque à retirer le masque
en extérieur c'est une question qui
paraît simple mais qui en fait compliqué
parce que port du masque son extérieur
il ya un peu de d'éléments concrets qui
plaide en sa faveur et ça dépend ce
qu'on appelle l'extérieur quand on est
dans une
dans un festival par exemple dehors avec
un monde
le port du masque à l'extérieur là une
utilité parce qu'il ya le premier suite
et oui on chante on rigole et c'est donc
là il ya des postillons donc des
aérosols et donc le virus le virus
circule en revanche quand on marche dans
une rue dans une forêt à la plage mais
même dans une ville un marché dans la
rue il ya quasiment aucun risque de
contamination
c'est ce que cette étude menée par un
groupe de chercheurs italiens démontre
clairement la probabilité de
transmission aéroportée due aux aérosols
respiratoires et très faible dans des
conditions extérieures
même si elle pourrait être plus
pertinente pour les environnements
intérieurs depuis le début de cette
vidéo nous avons simplement aborder la
question du masque en extérieur et la
raison pour laquelle on fait cette
nuance c'est parce que les risques de
contamination ils sont beaucoup plus
faibles
encore une fois les chiffres concernant
le covin semble être encourageants comme
on a pu le constater plutôt dans la
vidéo alors pourquoi est-ce que la fin
du masque en intérieur n'est pas encore
envisagée pour arriver à une à une
législation plus souple en intérieur
quand le virus aura définitivement
fini de circuler on y est presque mais
on n'y est pas encore et surtout on
n'est pas à l'abri d'avoir des robots
c'est les modèles situe pasteur été
publiée à quelques semaines qui
expliquait ça c'est qu'on pourra
considérer qu'on sera définitivement à
l'abri d'un d'une reprise épidémique en
90 % de la population adulte sera
vacciné donc ses 46 millions de
personnes en france
là à ce moment-là peut-être qu'on pourra
définitivement abandonnée d'un point de
vue coercitif le port du masque qui
après ce qui restera dans les habitudes
ces questions est ce qu'on pourrait
envisager une fin des masques et
définitive dans un futur proche
on peut espérer d'y aller encore de
manière de manière progressive
on remarque sur le masque c'est enfin
des préfectures qui ont la main il ya
des régions des départements le virus va
définitivement arrêtée circulé avant
d'autres on sait que l'oiseau la
français a toujours été plutôt épargnée
et que dans ces régions porter le masque
d'intérieur deviennent deviennent moins
utiles et deviennent même totalement
dispensable assez rapidement de manière
générale nous allons devoir continuer à
le porter comme certaines personnes que
nous avons interrogées tout à l'heure
plusieurs d'entre nous garderont
probablement le masque par habitude
c'est du moins ce que l'on pourrait en
déduire d'après ce sondage bva réalisé
au mois de mai 2021 qui souligne que
pendant que le port du masque était
encore obligatoire en extérieur 67% des
français soutenaient cette mesure et y
était favorable
le fait est qu'il ya sans doute beaucoup
de gens qui vont garder cette habitude
cas pendant pendant un certain nombre de
semaines un certain nombre de mois c'est
quelque chose dont on se rend compte
quand on discute autour de nous cette
année parce qu'il y avait des mesures à
barrière beaucoup de gens qui avaient
l'habitude de tomber malade d'avoir la
crypte la gastro n'ont pas eu d'autre ça
plutôt plutôt agréable et ce réflexe de
se protéger quand on prend les
transports en commun un peu pourra
s'inscrire dans la durée cette habitude
du port du masque à d'ailleurs été gardé
dans certaines régions d'asie
c'est qu'en asie du sud est il y à
beaucoup plus de risques épidémiques
parce que le rapport avec les zoonoses
donc les réserve animale le virus sont
qu'amas s'est dégradée donc
le virus circule beaucoup des sociétés
asiatiques ont été beaucoup traumatisé
par l'épisode du sahara en 2002 2003 le
port du masque a commencé à faire partie
des moeurs suite à l'épidémie de sras ce
qui a débuté en chine en 2002 avant de
se propager vers singapour et taïwan
l'année suivante et aujourd'hui nous
savons que le masque est toujours très
utilisé pour protéger de la pollution de
ces villes mais aussi par habitude et
vous est-ce que vous allez continuer à
garder l'habitude de porter le masque
dites le nous en commentaires
[Musique]
on